what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with spider-verse specifically
as promised we are covering edge of
spider-verse now for those of you guys
who don't know what that is edge of
spider-verse and we technically already
covered part one but edge of
spider-verse was a five-part mini-series
that basically covered the origins of
like different spider-esque characters
from across the multiverse some of whom
ended up joining the various you know
the great big huge spider-man team as
part of spider-verse and others who
actually were killed by the inheritors
so it's a really really cool concept
this one in particular is the origin of
spider gwen and this one's nuts because
here's a crazy thing when this story
came out it's one of those rare
instances in this day and age when a
character is introduced in comics and
immediately explodes in popularity it
was actually the costume that made
spider-gwen so popular when she first
came out because the costume design was
fantastic but like literally that year
at like comic-cons everywhere like you
just saw girls running around as like
spider-gwen it was it was nuts how
popular she was but what this does is it
initially opens up basically a midtown
high school right midtown being the
school that peter parker went to so a
lot of similarities that we know of
between this alternate reality uh
spider-man story and and the maine
marvel universe story but basically gwen
stacy plays in a band called the mary
janes which my initial idea was like man
how arrogant could you be that you named
a band after yourself but van halen did
the same thing and their band was
amazing uh the thing about this is that
we get this kind of flashback right now
this is her first appearance in comics
and so jason letour plays it fast and
quick with her origin in the sense that
all we really know is that basically she
was bitten by a radioactive spider and
that in turn she went on to become a
superhero but unlike the main marvel
universe where captain stacy the father
of gwen was someone that became a ally
of spider-man in this instance he's
actually an enemy of spider-gwen all the
while totally unaware of the fact that
his daughter is spider-gwen so that
added a really cool dynamic on top of
that peter parker never became
spider-man instead he's just basically
an introverted kid in a school that gets
picked on all the time and so gwen stacy
is the one saving him and in a pursuit
to become something comparable to her he
actually ended up becoming the lizard
instead and during some kind of a
conflict which is never explored here in
the story he basically ends up dying and
so following that what you get is jay
jonah jameson that puts forward this
idea that basically peter parker died at
the hands of spider-gwen and that he has
to be evinced right the superheroes are
basically being viewed as vigilante and
they can't be allowed to go around and
operate in that capacity right so the
cool thing about this is that with that
little bit out of a way she kind of gets
lost in herself as she's she's playing
in this band right just kind of getting
lost and sort of you know getting
carried away and of course you know
she's told by the band hey let's just
take a break right remember we have our
concert coming up and so you get
basically this kind of big uh struggle
that spider-wing goes through and this
is one of the things that really brought
a lot of people on board spider-gwen was
hugely popular among girls which if i'm
being honest with you guys marvel needed
that at the time right marvel didn't
have a whole lot of heroes that
resonated with the female audience and
so you know by and large there weren't a
whole lot of people that women could
have camaraderie with and so one of the
things that a lot of just young people
in general struggle with is like the
coming-of-age thing right a lot of you
guys who are in your teenage years and
those of you guys who remember your
teenage years you remember what it was
like right you're trying to fit in
you're trying to understand your place
in the bigger picture you're trying to
figure out who you are so you're making
friendships but you're not even sure if
the friends you have are going to be
your friends for the rest of your life
you want to make sure you maintain those
relationships but you also know you're
changing
it's a very very confusing and difficult
time that i think is exacerbated by the
nature of social media but the thing
about this is that she's basically
struggling with this idea that one part
of her feels guilt over the death of
peter parker but there's another part of
her that's like i'm not the one who's
responsible for this so while the world
is telling her it's your fault peter
died she knows it's not but she can
never really share her identity with
seemingly anybody around her let alone
her father her father's a cop and her
father's hunting spider-gwen
and so there's no real knowing what
would happen if she dumped her identity
to her father now there does come a
moment when she almost does when she
almost tells her dad who she is what's
going on you know and it kind of makes
sense right given the relationship
between her and her father and really
between most girls and their father that
as time progresses girls become closer
to their dads and then they become
closer to their moms and so in this
instance her father is the only real
parental figure she has it's the only
real person she feels like she can go
and talk to anything about and so if
there were any person she could have
this conversation with it would be him
but before she gets the chance she's
actually basically tracked down by a cop
who of course doesn't necessarily shoot
her on the spot but actually tries to
and that's kind of the extent of of how
she's viewed here that in some ways it
was pretty dark right he tells her like
freeze put her hands up you know all
that kind of stuff you know the things
you normally expect to hear when a cop
is like you know trying to arrest you
essentially and of course she's she's
dodging and moving out of the way and so
on and so forth but he fires a few shots
at her and tries to kill her and she
actually you know ends up in you know
basically webbing him up so he can't do
anything and then puts in a call saying
shots fired and you know a bunch of cops
show up and she actually makes her
escape and these cops continue tracking
her down what this does is it says
there's basically no safe place for
spider-gwen and this is starkly
different from the spider-man mythos
that we're used to and that was one of
the best things about edge spider-verse
because this is the tip of the iceberg
right wait till we get to the story
about the spider-man who bites mary jane
watson that gets nuts right that story
gets crazy it's like a horror story more
so than anything else what you actually
also end up getting here is basically
matt murdock who's actually a villain
right which is kind of crazy right it's
one of the cool things about this and so
you basically have him talking to alexi
who is really this alternate reality's
version of rhino from marvel comics is
really all he is but as the two of them
are talking basically he's being set
upon captain stacy right just a desire
to take this guy out because captain
stacy's not necessarily a bad cop right
like i mean he's trying to track down
spider gwen because in his mind she's a
criminal of vigilante as far as he's
aware he's doing what he's instructed to
do as a member of law enforcement but
more so than that he takes down big
criminals different things along those
lines so he's as much an issue for
spider-gwen as he is for like matt
murdock and any of those guys and so
following this of course as you expect
much like if you're familiar with
spider-man for the mini marvel universe
this girl can't be on time anywhere
that's kind of the thing about
spider-man right peter parker this guy
couldn't be on time if he had like a
giant purple clock sitting in front of
his face telling him what time it was
right he still couldn't be on time and
so ultimately she's actually late for
her own concert with the mary janes now
there is a little bit of a saving grace
here in the sense that like with no
drummer there people are kind of like i
mean this is a little weird seeing a
band with no drummer but then like alexi
busts in with the intention of going
after captain stacy right spider gwen
shows up just at that moment and of
course throws on her suit and then
immediately goes through to try to save
her dad but it's kind of a little bit of
a saving grace right before anybody
could realize hey this girl's missing
you know outside of the band like this
this band sucks right if it went on for
like 15 minutes people would be like
yeah this band sucks they don't have a
drummer this is weird let's let's go
next door and get some drinks
[Laughter]
that's basically what it would turn into
but you get this thing where rhino
actually gets the upper hand on her and
a lot of this seems to be because she's
still fairly new to this right she's
still fairly new to being a spider
character and understanding everything
that goes along with it the various
villains that are out there and even
with peter parker in the main marvel
universe it was much the same way peter
parker didn't know how to cope with
someone like electro until he fought
someone like elektra right it's just one
of those things you don't know how to do
it until you do and then you learn how
to go forward from there and so she's
able to get the upper hand just by
virtue of her enhanced strength and
actually overcomes this guy quite
readily i mean just absolutely pummels
this dude and then webs him up knocks
him unconscious and goes to walk away
only to be met by her father right for
like captain stacy to turn around just
be like you're under arrest and that's
kind of the crazy thing because you get
this really really cool exchange here
right it's almost this thing where like
she approaches it from a pretty
interesting philosophical level right he
says don't move an inch and she's like
really you know she's like what's a girl
got to do to impress a guy right so
obviously maintaining that kind of
joking thing you know she's like i just
want to be loved you know and so on and
so forth and then what happens is things
get serious right you know you get that
kind of peter parker-esque joking which
is sort of necessary for any kind of you
know alternate reality or any maine
marvel universe spider-man story but
when captain stacy goes to arrest her
he's like i'm placing you under arrest
for the murder of peter parker you have
the right to remain silent and that's
when she chimes in she's like peter's
death it was not my fault at least not
in the way that you think but captain
stacy doesn't care right you know he's
like it's not my job to decide that
she's like sure you'll just leave it to
jamison's angry mob right some crazy guy
who ramped up a bunch of crazy people
and they all want to take me out you
know she's like or you could leave it to
the cop that tried to shoot me in a
crowded subway but whatever the case is
and he's like whatever it takes right
however long it takes to to do it like
you'll see justice i will like you will
you will stand before a judge for the
crime that you committed and that's when
she unmasks right she's like i'm
spider-gwen she's like here's the thing
dad like you're a good cop you put on
the badge because you knew that if you
didn't somebody who doesn't need to wear
a badge would right somebody who would
abuse their power would do it and so you
are are in effect not necessarily super
powered but you're a person who does the
right thing and that's what i'm doing
right i'm putting on this mask i tried
to do the right thing peter parker got
himself killed he became a villain right
he became a bad guy you know whatever
the case was it unfolded in his
situation she's like i didn't kill peter
parker and if i'm going to be like you
and i'm going to be somebody who stands
up for small people like i'm going to be
somebody who makes the world a better
place i can't do it from a jail cell i
can't do it there so you have to let me
go right she's like this mask is my
badge now right if i don't define what
it means monsters like that will and
that's true right that's one of those
things where if you have a cause that
you're standing up for you have to have
a face of that cause otherwise you'll
become a kind of walking talking case
study where your opposition defines your
cause better than you do that's why i
always advocate every movement has to
have a leader otherwise you end up
having people who do things awry and
there's no one there to say they don't
stand for what we believe in and so
that's why she has to be out there in
doing this kind of thing because it's
not necessarily about her solidifying
what it means to be a hero to a degree
it is it's her solidifying the idea that
not everyone out there with powers is a
bad guy some of us are good guys and
some of us are trying to do good things
and so as a result of that i have to go
out and be one of the good people and
her dad lets her go right now the thing
about this is this is all being watched
by spider-man uk and his response is yes
you'll do quite nicely they're going to
bring her into their ranks now here's
the funny thing this story it was nuts
right like when this came out everybody
wanted to know everything about
spider-gwen they were like no no no you
can't give us some story in edge of
spider-verse like this and give us
nothing else again right because she
showed back up in the main spider-verse
event but she was so huge that marvel
marvel like had to create a story about
it right i mean it's sold like
gangbusters and so ever since then
spider-gwen's been like a mainstay in
marvel comics she's just that popular
and she probably always will be to be
honest i mean she's always written just
incredibly well but yeah that's the
origin of spider-gwen in marvel comics
if i'm being honest with you guys i
would not be surprised this video does
terrible but thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace